Danny and Rogen's dramatic rescue of Jon
Snow and his fellow warriors is one of
the most memorable scenes from season
seven of Game of Thrones but before that
scene came to life it started here in a
slightly less polished place before
filming ever began certain problems had
to be solved like how all the characters
will fit on the dragon and what they'd
hold to avoid falling off also what does
the dragon even look like building these
mythical creatures from scratch required
a combination of elements found in the
natural world like the scales of a
lizard the wings of a bat in the neck of
a t-rex all to create this I built that
gigantic thing in this little tiny
bedroom this is Dan catcher the
self-proclaimed father of dragons and
he's the man responsible for designing
these iconic creatures for one of the
biggest shows in television history
[Music]
the Game of Thrones dragons set a new
standard for how these creatures are
designed and brought to life for me
every season it would go from anywhere
from eight weeks to 12 weeks of actually
working and designing these guys it all
starts with a sketch like this early
drawing of drogon but it's not just
about sketching catcher creates detailed
models that he sends to HBO for approval
models that have to take into account
the proportions of the Dragons which
grew from tiny to massive during the run
of the show how the creatures would work
inside and out and every single detail
down to the individual scales to do this
catcher used a program called ZBrush the
first step for creating one of his 3d
models is creating the proportions of
the creatures using elements called
Zee spheres before he can think about
how the creature will look he has to
create the basic infrastructure for how
it will work pretty soon you see the
basic building blocks of a dragon
catcher then creates an internal
structure or skeleton he lays out bones
that will be connected to muscle
establishing the physical dynamics of
how this creature will move and
eventually plot an understanding of
physiology and Anatomy is crucial to
catchers designs many of which are
inspired by real-life animals in the
skeleton itself I've mixed all these
animals together so you've got bat wings
that are in the bones you've got a bird
ribcage these are neck vertebrae taken
from a Tyrannosaurus Rex for his dragon
catcher combined specific elements of
real animals the scales on the Dragons
head look like those of a sungazer
lizard and you'll notice the
similarities between the scales on its
chest and the feathers on the chest of
an eagle catcher puts his inspiration to
work in the most time-consuming part of
the process creating and refining the
extremely detailed features of the
dragons Anatomy like its teeth and its
scales are those ZBrush hash tools that
allow artists to repeat the patterns of
the scales thus saving time catcher
meticulously designs every scale himself
to avoid the appearance of artificiality
once the detailed model is complete and
ZBrush catcher exports a 2d image to
perform a paint over for an image that
submitted to producers for approval
but the initial design is only the
beginning catcher would be given the
storyline which would determine specific
modifications that needed to be made for
each dragon like in that scene in season
seven so I had to show like all right
well here's how all the guys can hold on
to the scales and Rogen's back to
eventually be pulled away so that's like
part of the design process
catcher exports his files from ZBrush
and sends them to visual effects
companies who import the files into
programs like Maya and 3d studio max to
begin rigging and animating the
creatures that you see come to life on
screen the technology now is at the
point where really if you can conceive a
fit you can make it so how do you get a
job designing dragons
I was working on a show called Terra
Nova with dinosaurs and a gentleman by
the name of Rainer Gambas came in who
happened to be the executive producer
for the visual effects for Game of
Thrones and he was looking for a dragon
and it just so happened that I had spent
my life making dinosaurs and dragons
like for McFarlane Toys years before
getting hired as a game of Thrones
capture worked as a toymaker designing a
sculpting creature figurines for spawn
creator Todd McFarlane's new york-based
toy company I had already had a pretty
big portfolio of different dragon works
to show them so I didn't have to do
another concept on top and that they
they just sort of looked at my work and
Ranger trusted me and said we see you
know what you're doing just just go for
it so that design was always in me and
finally Game of Thrones just let it come
out
catcher received Emmy recognition for
his work on Game of Thrones
today he's busy creating creatures for
DC ships like the flash Titans and
Supergirl
that was the design I did for the ice
dragon which I had to keep secret for
two years before it was ever released
even my wife did not see that whose
everybody was like especially my wife
was like don't you tell me what happened
don't show me anything on your computer
I don't want to know until the show
comes out